lives lost society disrupted in ways we
haven't seen since the Second World War
our very way of life put on hold
and perhaps changed forever but also a
crisis that might provide a chance to
build something new something better
this is life after the pandemic and our
new world
[Music]
good evening I'm German moanin and this
week we've heard from some of the
world's most eminent figures in the
fields of politics business and science
and tonight we consider our society and
culture with us a new live virtual
studio audience once again joining us
from around the world they're going to
provide the questions about how we can
build a new future very welcome to you
all
now answering them Nicola Mendelsohn the
vice president of Facebook in Europe the
Middle East and Africa we've also got
the musician a professor of poetry
Benjamin Zephaniah the author and
journalist Lionel Shriver who thinks the
lockdown should never have happened
and our quartet tonight his set made up
completed with the astronomer royal and
futurologist professor Rees who says the
fate of future generations will depend
on how we respond to this pandemic very
good evening to you all but before then
we can hear now from the Prince of Wales
who has spoken exclusively to our royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills about his
experience of coronavirus and what life
might be like after the pandemic thank
you so much for talking to us this is a
slightly peculiar unusual way of doing
an interview we are living in very
unusual times at the moment and I wanted
to start off by asking you what have
been your reflections of the the impact
that this pandemic has had on our
country I can't tell you how much I
sympathize with the way everybody has
had to enjoy this unbelievably testing
and challenging time and I I know that
so many people have had the agony of
losing you know their loved ones and the
bewilderment and anxiety that surrounds
everything and so it is the most awful
aspect of a pandemic like this and and
yet we've seen at the same time people
being quite remarkable and wonderful
people in National Health Service and
all the other key
workers who kept everything going what
do you think it is taught us about our
priorities what what really matters in
life at the moment we have to put nature
back at the center of everything we do
and put it at the center of our economy
which is before this it's been nature's
has been pushed to the peripheries we've
exploited and dug up and cut down
everything as if there was no tomorrow
if it didn't matter the problem is of
course it does matter as some people
have been trying to say for a long time
that the more we erode the natural world
the more we destroy what's called
biodiversity which is the immense
diversity of life plant life tree light
everything else this marine life the the
more we expose ourselves to this kind of
danger and we've had these other
disasters you know with SARS and Ebola
and goodness knows what else all of
these things are related to the loss of
biodiversity they're called zoonotic
diseases where you end up with with
these diseases being transferred from
animals to humans if you over erode the
natural world so we have to find a way
this time to put nature back at the
center and that is the way in which if
we live in greater harmony we can find a
much more sensible form of economy it's
fascinating what you say that because I
know that we've spoken in the past about
your concerns that if we don't act now
we are going to see more natural
disasters but you're also saying there
that that we could see more pandemics
like this well this is what so many of
the scientists who understand these
things have been trying to say for a
long time and I'm it's one of the
reasons I tried to to get the point
across that we should have been treating
the planet as if it was a patient long
ago so no self-respecting doctor would
ever have let the situation if the
planet is a patient reached this stage
before making an intervention hence you
know the precautionary principle which
seems to me
absolutely essential what do you think
are the key priorities the key themes
that we really need to be looking at in
a post covet world well first of all we
need to work at how do we create the
kind of recovery that benefits people
helps to get people back to work again
provides real employment around the
world and that can be done of course by
prioritizing certain things that haven't
been prioritized before which is to
recognize the damage being done by back
co2 it seems like very long time ago but
but in January you launched the
sustainable markets Council a lot has
changed since then is it now time to rip
up the rulebook or are you still feeling
confident that that could be a good
basis for through a global economic
model going forward yes I think you can
I mean I've been as I think I said
before I've been absolutely amazed by
well the transformation that's taken
place in the last year or two in terms
of the financial services sector and the
capital market sector suddenly taking an
interest in sustainable investment
opportunities do you appreciate that
there there is a fear that that maybe
this crisis has made individuals less
receptive to sort of vision visions of
change many people are still at home
they'll be watching this thinking well
I'm still concerned like my family could
get ill I'm concerned that I don't
necessarily know whether I'm going to
have a job going forward what would you
say what would you say about that the
most important thing obviously is to
make sure the economy can function again
and that people's livelihoods and their
businesses and everything else and
employment is possible that all these
things are going to be have to be
incremental anyway but the point is that
in order to avoid even worse situations
in the future and more disease and we
have to we have to find a way to ensure
that within the next ten years because
otherwise we will lose this battle
against accelerating
and this global warming because if we go
on like this with temperatures rising
inexorably then the whole of life
becomes increasingly impossible how much
will you be pushing for for global
leaders to step up now and and come
together what is a time when actually
many countries could feel disjointed and
be quite inward looking as they try and
fix their own their own economies I
haven't exactly been wasting my time
during this lockdown if you know what I
mean so I've been you know in connection
with all sorts of people have had the
opportunity to do a lot using this
technology I have been communicating
with a lot of people around the world on
these issues it's only catastrophes
which concentrate the mind which means
that for once there might be some real
impetus to tackle all these things which
would be pushed to one side because
everybody to know it's it's irrelevant
to differences you could never get the
g20 to concentrate very much on
agriculture forestry or fisheries
because it wasn't considered very sexy
but but these are crucial things this
globally has affected everybody and it's
affected everybody a very personal ways
for example you had the virus yourself
how much did that motivate you to look
at it what can be done next and aware we
go forward yes it makes me more
determined to push and shove and shout
and prod if you see what I mean and
whatever I can do behind the scenes
sometimes but but yes I mean I I I
suppose it did party I mean I was lucky
in my case and and and got away with it
quite likely but I've had it and I
cannot say oh understand what other
people have gone through and and I feel
particularly for those for instance who
you know lost the lovers but we're
unable to to be
with them at the time that's to me the
most ghastly thing but but in order to
prevent this happening to so many more
people this is why I'm so determined to
find a way how out of this people are
just desperate to see their families
already don't they it's it's a it's a
challenging time well I mean I haven't
seen my father for a long time he's he's
going to be 99 next week and so yes all
my grandchildren or anything so I've
been doing but the face time is all very
well how has that been for you being
being disconnected from from your family
it's terribly sad then let alone one's
friends but unfortunately you know at
least you can speak to them on
telephones and occasionally do this sort
of thing but it isn't the same is it you
want to you really want to give people a
hug it's been absolutely fascinating
talking to you thank you very much for
taking time and hopefully we will all
meet up again in in the ways that that
we usually do so thank you very much sir
I do hope anyway Thank You Raylan thank
you the Prince of Wales there on the
stresses that coronavirus has placed on
all families over the last few months
and that chimes with our first question
from our virtual audience tonight it
comes from Natasha eco-resort who's in
South East London very good evening to
you Natasha and very good evening to all
our audience there Natasha would you get
us started please with your question hi
good evening Derman my question is about
social relationships when our social
relationships ever be the same as they
were precoded surely everyone has an
inner fear or lack of trust about the
people they interact with from now
onwards mmm good question well I tell
you what so let's stay with our audience
and let's ask you all about Natasha's
question how many of you actually agree
with that people are now more
mistrustful of people you interact with
now just a show of hands if you would
hands up if you feel more uneasy about
general what used to be everyday social
interactions how
sup if you feel uneasy well well well
that's whoo maybe 80% maybe maybe more
than 80% nearly everyone well let's talk
to our panelists then very good evening
to you all Nicola Mendelssohn then and I
mean in a way is that almost music to
the ears of your platform in that people
are they're not going to meet personally
they're going to interact online and
thank you for the question and I
couldn't start tonight without just
acknowledging George Floyd's memorial
and the fact that my heart is with his
family friends might be like friends and
the black community and I and I think so
much of what we're talking about here
tonight is around that you know our new
world
I certainly hope our new world is one
where people can come together which is
also Natasha's question here how do we
feel about people know I miss people I
haven't seen people in a very long time
and I can't wait to be in a world where
we can interact in the same way as we
once did but I do also think that the
way that we live in the way that we work
has changed in so many different ways
but deep down were human beings we like
to be around other people and I think
that yes we can find different ways to
come together through social media
through video calling and we've seen so
much of that which has been such a
blessing can you imagine of going
through this period without the ability
to use technology to be in touch with
our loved ones would have been so
difficult but yet we're in for a period
where we are going to be still more
socially distanced from people but I
almost think that there's a kindness in
that because we're doing that to protect
all of us and I think that's an
important thing to Benjamin Zephaniah
and I should say that clearly our all
our sympathies of course with George
Floyd's family as memorial services just
taking place is taking place in
Minneapolis and we will be directly
addressing that issue in a moment or two
but just just on this issue of social
distancing lack of social interaction
Benjamin Zephaniah the idea now that
people are scared of interacting with
each other
well it's it's natural but we need to I
remember a few years ago I was touring
around the world a very very successful
tour I was in Thailand I was in India I
was in Pakistan I was meeting all these
people shaking their hand which was okay
but I got to Malaysia and I met a lady
from the British Council and she was
British and she hooked me and this
electricity even through my body I
realize I haven't been hugged for so
long and I was telling a fellow poet
anyway that's a beautiful chat applying
because I said please hug me again I
just realized how much I missed human
touch and so we I once said to a friend
of mine that we are pack animals then he
collected me say be not pack animals we
are social animals we do like to touch
each other we do like to hug each other
we do like to really connect and me
personally I am quite nervous about it
just because I know of the reality let
me lay my cards down here I've lost two
members of my family to this Kovach 19
my sister was very close to death and
the day she came out of hospital she
came out from the Saturday morning her
husband went in on the afternoon she got
it very badly physically but he hasn't
recovered mentally because of what he
saw in that hospital and when they tell
me what they went through I think I
don't want to go through that so I can
be a tough guy at time but I'm pretty
scared right now Benjamin what a
traumatic time for you and your family
our condolences our deepest sympathies
go to you what I want to do now though
is some bring in some of our
wide-ranging opinion polling that we've
been conducting for these programs about
the future facing the world it feeds
into Natasha's question let me bring you
some of the findings now we asked has
the experience of growing a virus
changed how close your relationships are
and 39% of people told us they felt
closer to their children while 4% sell
said they felt less close 37% said they
felt closer
to their spouse or partner 7% saying
they felt less close and 32% of those
surveyed said they felt closer to their
neighbors while 4% said they were now
less close well let's say continue on
this theme then and Lionel Shriver there
we see it people we're feeling closer to
those around them their family their
close friends and indeed their their
neighbors but scared of strangers yeah
and I think there's a real loss they're
part of the experience of living in a
city is is being around strangers and
and having an amicable relationship
ideally around strangers and I think
this whole thing of social distancing
and having having to be two meters apart
to queue for the supermarket just
noticed it's it has a poisonous effect
on how we relate to each other when we
don't know one another we're not looking
at each other we're not smiling
nobody talks nobody makes any small
talks there no little jokes and one of
my worries about the so-called new
normal is that we're going to carry this
on perhaps indefinitely so that's it
that is a huge change to the texture of
daily life and I I think it makes us
more mistrustful we are being trained to
regard one another as walking diseases
walking contaminants and you know the
truth is we have lived always with
people as potential contaminants and we
were used to it and suddenly we've
become dangerously unused to it and I
think we have to return to the point at
which you realize ok you shake
somebody's hand maybe they'll give you a
cold well professor Reese this mistrust
of others and new habits and new ways of
interacting being learned that will last
terrible
if this distancing continues it may well
continue because if we don't have a
virus then we're going to have
recurrence of this endemic and of course
and M explain themselves were
an important Maxim is that the
unfamiliar is not the same as improbable
so we may be landed with the current
ones but of course what is going to do
probably is change the way we work it's
going to perhaps encourage more home
working and less commuting five days a
week to the office and that of course
has its upsides as well as downsized so
it may be in a sense good for a family
life but it may also be bad for
socializing at work so it's going to
change the way we work and the way we
live and the balance between our
friendships at work and the ones we make
in other ways is I think going to change
and I think one other point is going to
rise in this is that we're going to use
our homes differently because if it
turns out that more people work from
home we're going to find that most of
the homes we have are too small too
cramped if their work placed as well
we need to hope that future homes are
larger but the balance between home and
work is clearly going to change well
let's get a nervous question from our
virtual audience
Raffaello Marioni in north london has a
question good evening Raffaello what
would you like to ask thanks Donna hi
panel what you saying my question is
released this week public health
England's beim report showed how people
of color had between 10 to 50 percent
higher risk of dying from Koba 19 than
white British people compounded by
George Floyd's brutal murder and the
powerful memorial we've just seen is
very clear that institutional racism
still defines countries including our
own as we look to rebuild society after
the pandemic will government and
society's institutions finally and
meaningfully address systemic racism all
black lives continue to not matter well
thank you for that Raffaello as I say as
George Floyd's memorial service has just
been taking place in Minneapolis and
Benjamin Zephaniah two very different
events of course but do they both
highlight for you the the dimensions of
the same issue
well where do I start I mean
look my mother came to Britain in 1956
and her dream was to work for the
National Health Service and that's what
she did for most of her life most of my
family are what we now call frontline
workers up until recently they would
call low paid workers you know when
nurses went on strike for better pay and
better condition they were mean and
suddenly people have got to appreciate
what these people do now we do see that
black people are dying in higher numbers
and I don't quite understand the reasons
for that I understand but we tend to
live in multi-generational homes there
is a high level of diabetes amongst a
lot of the elderly black community but
not long ago there was this whole thing
about Windrush and brexit and sending us
home and all this kind of stuff we were
kind of I mean I used to get racist
attacks in the 70s and 80s and they kind
of went away suddenly they were back I
felt like I was unwanted in my country
and then this pandemic comes we're all
indoors if you're not indoors if my
family are not indoors we are in
hospitals trying to save the nation's
lives and then this thing happens in
America and it didn't just happen in
America in 2003 my cousin Mikey Powell
was killed in almost exactly the same
way as George Floyd was killed please
look it up don't just take my word for
it it's official
the inquest said the coroner said he
died by asphyxiation
he had a plea police officers foot in
his neck
this is happening to black people all
the time so I think that is a kind of
perfect storm you feel like that's
happened recently and we've just said
we're gonna get out on the streets we
can't take it anymore things have got to
change and they've got to change on so
many levels I'm gonna try and stop
talking about but it's got to change on
what we I don't normally agree that not
reprinted childhood when he talks about
nature this is really really important
we have to change and I speak to the
vegan of a relationship with animals and
nature and we have to change our
relationships with ourselves
black lives really do matter and we're
fed up of them not mattering and that is
getting lots of applause unanimous
applause they're from our audience
Benjamin and Nicola Mendelsohn I want to
go to you you touch of course upon it in
your first answer to a cinder addressing
directly Raphael owes question there
he's looking to government and societies
institutions to finally and meaningfully
address systemic racism now of course
Facebook is now one of society's major
institutions hugely influential address
for us what your company is doing so we
are doing a lot in this area the first
thing that is a company we've made a
declaration that in the next five years
we want half of our employees to be from
underrepresented minorities because we
want the people at Facebook that are
building the products to actually be
representing the people that are using
our products all over the world and
we're actually publishing our numbers in
terms of how we're doing we've been
doing that for the last six years and we
are making progress but we're not
satisfied and we and we want to move
quicker we think that there's more that
we can do and so we we think about this
from how we think about recruitment we
think about this from how we practice
inclusion we think about this from the
training that we do with our with our
people in terms of helping people to
understand their bias and let's face it
everybody has bias and if you think you
haven't got bias you're probably one of
the most biased people out
and so that's an obligation that we can
all take upon ourselves because
ultimately it starts with people and
it's not just to say enough to say that
you know I don't agree with racism
you've got to say I'm anti-racist and
I'm committed to taking action and what
we're seeing at the moment is that
there's a lot of people that wanna help
and want to be part of the action and I
think the onus is on all of us
across society across institutions
across business to make sure that we
keep the momentum up and that we make
sure that we continue to help and work
with our black communities and the wider
black community as well because this has
to stop i Benjamin I saw you wanted to
make a further point you know this one
I've been in contact with Aboriginal
communities in Australia New Zealand all
over the world and one thing that is
different now and I think you because of
the way it was filmed and social media
is that once upon a time when these
things happened when we complained about
them we were called black militants and
were druggies now the white community
the international community has seen it
they've seen it they can replayed they
can count the minutes and watch this guy
dying and so it's kind of wonderful to
the stranger to you but it's great to
see black live matters marches that are
full of white people sometimes the black
people are outnumbered and this is a
great thing to see because now so many
people get it and it's great to see so
many young people getting it well I
don't know if you could see Raphael Oh
Mario Nia asking his question there but
he is of course benjamine one of those
white supporters of black lives matters
now a professor Ries I saw you wanted to
get in after Benjamin's original answer
then but can I can I add in there your
analysis of a recipe for instability is
institutional racism part of that I
think one of the benign possibility this
endemic is going to be a greater
realization of who actually matters who
is important in society because
obviously we've learned
not just doctors and nurses but people
in care homes bus drivers people at
checkouts in supermarkets all these
people they're important and of course
what's been happening in this country is
that the inequality the gap between
those people and the better off has been
getting wider and I certainly hope that
everyone realized that not only black
lives matter but the light of those who
are now as it were at the bottom of the
heap underappreciated and less secure
will lead to a reform in society that
reduces these great inequalities a
Lionel Shriver institutional racism are
these the triggers to finally address it
properly do you think institutional
racism exists I'm not big on the term
I'm not sure that it's very helpful it's
so overarching in some ways it leaves
you helpless because it's too big in
fact tonight I don't especially think
it's useful either to throw all these
issues and events together as one big
salad of badness particularly I wouldn't
throw in the Floyd case with the fact
that grievously minority communities
have suffered a higher fatality rate
from kovat 19 it is not understood
entirely why it seems to be a lot of
factors one of which is the occupying
frontline positions service jobs that
lead to a high exposure to the rest of
the community but there are things about
that distinction that we we don't know
and it isn't intentional you know it is
not some conspiracy it's not a plot it's
a it's a terrible misfortune and we need
to understand it and just saying that oh
this is this must be the result of
systemic racism doesn't get us anywhere
well thank you for that listen we can
pick up on a point now made by Nicola
Mendelssohn in our next question this
comes from Kara
to soluz who's in reading hello Carolina
what would you like to ask hi Facebook
and Google and other platforms announce
that they will fight fake news regarding
the pandemic however is seeing an
increase of fake news everywhere what
there's about Cova China or anything the
high majority of users are not fact
check and believe misleading information
shouldn't these platforms be more
accountable for the concert shares so
Nicola Mendelsohn what are you actively
doing to combat fake news some in huge
amounts of information coming in every
single minute how do you manage it so we
are doing a huge amount and we manage it
in a combination of using Fez of all
deep investments that we've made on
machine learning and artificial
intelligence but also we have over
35,000 people that we employ around the
world but also we need human review
because the machines still can't do
everything on top of that we are working
with over 60 fact-checking organizations
around the world and we'd already built
all these muscles up before the pandemic
arose and therefore we could put all the
learnings in that we that we've gone in
order to make sure that we could get
this off our platform because we don't
want it and I'll be really clear it
doesn't matter who says it but if
there's anything there that is a threat
to real-life bomb when it comes to the
pandemic or anything impact on our
platforms we just take it down we have
no place for it now if this hours are
going to go on to say that if there are
things on there that perhaps might be
differences of opinions but we have
independent fact checkers that say
actually this is something that should
be labeled with a warning then we'll put
that warning on and what our data tells
us is then that ninety-five percent of
people don't bother to go on and read
that information on the posts so we're
doing a lot in this but doesn't that
then mean that Facebook has gone from
being what it was originally a neutral
platform as you like to define yourself
you're now a publisher you're
responsible for the content that appears
there well we've always felt we've had a
responsibility to make sure no
real-world harm comes to people that's
incredibly important but actually the
decision made
here is coming from people like the
World Health Organization it's coming
from health ministries from different
countries and other experts we're not
experts in this era we look to others to
be able to do that for us and we're a
different sort of organization from a
traditional publisher like like sky or
like a newspaper but we are something
different but we do look to independent
third party experts to be able to advise
here Carolina I'd like to know what your
view is on your own question do you
think the likes of Facebook are doing
enough I think there's still a lot of
misleading information out there and
should be put down I know that we're not
we don't want to shut people's are
people ideas but I think there's a lot
of can be done especially because
education is one of the basic rights and
I find that a lot of this information
basically it goes against any type of
education we should receive very
misleading and I just sometimes just
promotes anger and yeah that's basically
my opinion thank you thank you once
again Carolina well let me put that to
Professor reason that's broaden it out
the question mentions Cove it over you
know so many issues where there's so
much fake news and misinformation around
China as well and we know it's use of
tech is society evolving certainly in
the West to the the big companies the
big organizations knowing so much about
us and controlling us in some ways and
then at the state level nations like
China doing just the same I think that's
true I think we have tension between
privacy freedom and security and
different parts of the world adventure
is differently but on the issue of fake
news I think there is a endemic problem
of social media because in the old days
most people got their information
somehow filtered through fairly
responsible journalists now everyone
whoever extreme has a voice and if you
click on something extreme you get sent
to something even more extreme so
opinion gets polarized on every issue
and
I just don't see how this can be dealt
with by the companies themselves I think
it's a real serious downside of the
social media which of course have an
upside in connecting the world but it
does polarize opinion rather than
mulling the extremes which used to
happen when we depended on organized
major media for information and Lionel
Shriver how concerned are you about a
big tech if I can call it that making
huge inroads during this crisis well I
found it very disturbing that during the
walk down especially sites like YouTube
have taken it upon themselves to remove
from public access interviews with often
very distinguished scientists who happen
to believe that the lockdown does a
great deal more harm than good but this
isn't the official message that's
approved and therefore it's regarded as
faked news so it's it's one thing to say
oh you know there there's too much hate
and we have to we have to control all
that awful and bad information but we
also need broad information we need
access to a breath of an opinion and I
think that the way social media has
increasingly behaved during the lockdown
period is sets an ominous precedent for
the kind of social and political control
that they are able to exert if they
decide to well answer that directly
Nicola Mendelsohn you're taking too
narrow of you now no I don't believe we
are and in fact actually if you look at
the data again you'll find out that
actually people have a much broader
circle of friends much broader array of
places that they get their information
from if I think about when I was growing
up I grew up in Manchester we had three
TV channels and one newspaper came into
my house my reference that the news was
very limited and now I have you know
great big smorgasbord of different
opinions and different facts that are
coming in from different places but I
think what we're also reflecting here is
that the it's people that use social
media
and actually it does reflect the the
different types of people that are using
it as well in as much as they were good
and there are bad in the world and what
we're trying to do is to make sure that
we can get rid of the bad off our
platform and I've been very clear about
how we do that but much more important
here as to how it can be a place for a
voice whether it's about campaigning
which we've already just talked about or
it can be a place for communities to
come together and especially through
this pandemic you know if I think about
how communities have arisen and come
together and found one another whether
it's through you know in the local areas
we've now seen there's 2 million people
in the UK that are a member of a local
group that's been set up to do with the
pandemic and those are groups that are
doing shopping for neighbors and they're
helping their elderly they're helping
the vulnerable what would have those
people have done if they hadn't have
been able to connect if they hadn't have
been able to discover who their
neighbors were that were there to help
and I've seen think about what we've
been doing on a Thursday night for the
last three months that was set up on
social media it was a May was the only
moment in the week that I saw anybody
else I was out on the streets okay away
yeah for so many millions of us what are
your thoughts on it then Benjamin
Zephaniah as Nicola Mendelssohn would
tell us an unmitigated force for good I
have a website and a person to build my
website said Benjamin you have to have a
Facebook and a Twitter and I have them
and I think I opened my facebook for the
first time for two years the other day I
look at Twitter every now and again and
I tweet things I don't go there for
serious intellectual debate I'm afraid I
don't if I want news I go to the
mainstream news and I'm very suspicious
of them and then I go to a website write
Declassified you look at British foreign
policy or gorilla news network which is
just people giving you news from council
estates around the world and if a family
in South America and places like that
so oh i mean when it comes to kobe 19
and stuff like that I go to my
university I look at this science fair
and then I compare that with what other
scientists are saying and I'm not a
scientist but
have very interesting debates and I
don't understand all of it but that's
where I go I take the time to find my
truth because I know that you can't get
truth in so few characters I looked on
the internet some not so long ago and it
said about me that I lived in Indonesia
it said that I've never lived in
Indonesia I've never been there but one
point it said I had a girlfriend I was
trying to find a girlfriend it was
really cramping my style
I mean yeah I didn't ever girlfriend so
so I don't go there for serious stuff
it's just play stuff I'm sorry I just
don't take it that seriously because
I've seen not just the fight news but
them lies if you want to know about
what's happening in the black community
trust me you can only find part of the
truth on social media you've got to go
to the community centers you've got to
go to the people
oh go at least two very websites
Benjamin I think you speak for an awful
lot of people what you've been saying
they're certainly our audience there are
a lot of them agreeing with you let's go
now to some of the results from that
exclusive opinion poll we've conducted
about life after the pandemic
here's another dimension we asked people
to think about their habits once the
outbreak is over 47 percent of those
surveyed thought people would continue
to work from home if they could 40
percent said people would still travel
to work just under half then continuing
to work from home closer to half now 49
percent of those polled said people
would shop more online 39 percent said
that people would go back to the shops
and 49 percent said they thought people
would take overseas holidays again but
37 percent said they believed people
would take fewer holidays overseas and
just more than half 51 percent told us
they thought people would socialize more
in person when the outbreak is over but
30 percent said people would continue to
socialize more on line a lot of what
we've already been discussing well
professor Rees let me put this to you
then from that because you were touching
on it already there this working from
home shopping online etc etc is this a
seismic shift
I think it is and understandable it is
very convenience but people will still
want chocolate it but in terms of travel
um I think air travel is most unlikely
years the returns of the old norm the
harder more vexatious that now is we're
going to have health best as well as
security we get on the plane and this
will discourage it and of course going
back to what the Prince of Wales says
the beginning this is perhaps good for
the planet but first one of the most
intractable types of co2 emission to
deal with is that associated with air
travel so I suspect we are going to have
less air travel in future even when
we've got bacne is a normal and probably
more virtual holidays or on this near
near home but I think it's very
important to realize that the world is
far more interconnected not so much by
air travel which of course at the
downside of allowing the virus to spread
in a few days but also by social media
where panic and rumor spreads the speed
of light and we have those features the
world to deal with now well I was wrong
it doesn't it all me now what what we've
been discussing earlier in the evening
in the attitudes we've found it
people are gonna get awfully isolated
it's gonna be a lot of loneliness out
there well I just think this whole new
normal was wrongheaded I think we should
be having our eye on the time that we
can return to being social our cities
are designed around high density webbing
and we can't immediately adapt them to
low density glut living we can't keep
running the tube at 10% capacity we
can't even have West End theatres if
every there you can only sit in every
third or fourth seat it's not viable and
I really think that we're in danger of
first overreacting to a virus that it
turns out is only somewhat more lethal
than a bad flu but then we're going to
drag the overreaction further into the
future and even talk about making some
of these errors
permanent and I I just think that's a
festival of self-destruction okay well I
want to put this then to audience and
ask you there you are again let's have
another straw poll get those elbows
greased and I want to put this to you
after the pandemic do you think your
daily lives will go back to how they
were or will they be significantly
different in the ways that our poll was
addressing as well so hands up please if
you think that your lives will be
significantly different in terms of work
travel and shopping and things like that
significantly different hands up
well well well there we are I say what
that's so well over 90 95 percent or
something like that oh I know what we've
got sadef nudge me in leads wants to
talk to us as well along those lines
hello sturdy firm tell us what you'd
like to say I don't and hello to
everybody on the panel and just with
regards to social media I just wanted to
say that what's up has played a
particularly crucial role in connecting
my street and some of you might have
been following the sign news video
diaries I sent a letter out our
neighbors and we made a whatsapp group
and now we've got over 50 households on
that group so if we did not have what's
up we would not be able to connect with
each other to that level also through
Facebook we've connected 6,000 people
across West Yorkshire in a support group
which is a regional support group again
without Facebook that would not have
been possible and I think during the
beginning of the pandemic as well when
the government was not able to step in
it was people and social media that was
taking you know the frontline and
connecting community stepping in helping
the vulnerable my question today is
should the government and social media
companies a liaison more to help
individuals especially in providing you
know ways for those clusters vulnerable
or find ways to connect with wider
Beauty going forward in the future well
Nicola Mendelssohn positively purring
there when who insidee was making that
point about community being enabled
through Facebook and the like but that
last point that some she was making
about working with governments and I'm
thinking you know in terms of using your
mighty power to help help for instance
the British government with its apps and
things like that so the experiences of
you is actually the experience of people
up and down the country and my own
experience I'm ashamed that I didn't
really know all the neighbors on my
street and we had one of my neighbors as
a pharmacist who actually the whole way
through the pandemic has been doing
people's prescriptions to mimic minimize
the amount of people that needed to go
out so I hope that that's something
that's going to continue in our new
world in terms of how we work with
government we already are we work very
closely with government and the whole
way through the virus what we have done
is that that the top of everybody's
newsfeeds
we've had an information hub where
people can find information in the first
instance it started off around medical
information and giving guidance and that
was done if you like to release the
pressure that was on things like 901 one
one or 999 just to help and give advice
there but latterly it's also increased
to be able to offer more areas around
volunteering if people want to get
involved or what groups are in your
local area so it is something that we
have been actively involved in we see
it's our responsibility to make sure
that we continue to play that role going
forward and professor Reece well you
know this close collaboration between
likes of Facebook and and governments
this this big issue here isn't there
about democracy whose democratically
accountable the government's are
Facebook isn't absolutely and the
problem really is that in order to
regulate these multinational global
corporations we need to have some kind
of international regulations personal
scandal is how little tax they pay but
have two separate issue but the point is
that they're regular need to be
regulated globally and this needs an
organization which is as global as the
World Health Organization
is that Atomic Energy Agency and those
other bodies which a global and we don't
yet have that and is next the problem I
think in that going back to the tensions
between privacy freedom and security
that balance would be set differently in
China from in the United States and
properties send me to meet it way in
Europe and so the regulation may have to
reach a rather than global but certainly
it can't be just national given the
scale of these companies Benjamin I just
want to get your thoughts sir given
we're talking almost throughout the
course of this hour about the migration
online you are you're a performer
nothing can beat a live performance in
front of a proper audience you know that
I know it a bit uh-huh so what we need
to discuss is are you ever going to be
able to do that again to see their eyes
to see their faces to see them smiling
well they might even be there there
might be wearing face masks perhaps you
might not even be seeing them smiling no
more festivals no more sports events
what are you gonna do I'm so lucky that
I've just finished two years of major
touring just came to an end as a knock
down started more or less a comedian
friend of mine in Germany told me that
he's been performing and remember dogs
kind of drive-in movies and then in the
United States kind of like that he's on
stage and the people sit in their cars
and instead of clapping they move their
window wipers or flashed their lights
and strangers fingers that maybe we
should try that and I really wouldn't
like that but because I run out of time
soon so I gotta say this a lot of people
say these are unprecedented times is a
strange weird times I'm a vegan we saw
this coming
you know viruses go from animals to
humans all the time and usually we get
on top of them every now and again we
don't and be not on top of this one yet
it's okay having Facebook and Twitter as
almost like emergency kind of resources
and maybe we can use them in very
interesting ways afterwards but I tell
you when I am in my work at university I
mean I've tried to do tutorials with
students online and I've done them but
nothing like sitting in front of your
student being able to read their body
language I'm not just sitting there and
going right we've got to do this we've
got to do that but saying how are you
today how does it be you know what's
life on campus like all that kind of
stuff
to just get people relaxed and see the
human side of them rather than just the
purely kind of academic side and get
them to answer the questions in the
right way we is going back to something
I said before we need that human touch
and I can't wait to get back to meet the
old normal got us here the new normal is
gonna take us somewhere else Benjamin
what fine words I don't think anyone
could disagree with that thank you very
much indeed oh look at that round of
applause well you're gonna be using your
hands again in just a moment audience
because it's almost it for tonight but I
want to do a final straw poll from you
lots so take your hands apart and use
one of them or maybe both I don't know
you can vote twice if you like by a show
of hands overall after what you've heard
this evening are you optimistic or
pessimistic about the future of society
so let's get the optimists let's hope
this plenty of you hands up if you're
optimistic please now well there we are
I think we had a few more than 50 there
are some family groupings there we don't
mind the more the merrier thank you all
very much indeed it wasn't that a
heartening way to end it this evening
gotta give my thanks to our panelists
tonight wonderful panel we've got to
Nicola Mendelssohn of course professor
Benjamin Zephaniah Lionel Shriver and
professor Martin Rees thank you all very
much indeed for your input and your
insight this evening and thanks to of
course to everyone in our virtual studio
audience tonight and the 200 audience
members we've hired across the week
thank you all for taking part and your
questions on your way so very good night
to you thank you very much indeed so
then we've spent four nights looking
into the future and we've heard warning
said the virus is almost certainly here
to stay in some form that we're facing a
grave economic crisis and that our whole
world
and social lives are unlikely to be the
same again sir you know that this
evening but we've also heard how the
crisis should bring about a new era of
international cooperation force the
world to finally address climate change
properly and maybe even introduce a wave
of creative scientific and technological
advances we can only hope well this has
been after the pandemic our new world
thank you very much indeed for watching
good night
[Music]